when vladimir putin ordered the invasion
of ukraine
is this what he planned the wholesale
destruction of sways of ukrainian cities
entire units of his military wiped out
their weapons destroyed or handed over
not according to british and american
officials today who say his ill-advised
ukrainian misadventure has ended in
abject failure in many ways putin has
already lost far from being the
far-sighted manipulator of events that
he would have us believe
putin has damaged himself through a
series of catastrophic misjudgments he
allowed himself to be misled as to his
own strength
including the effectiveness of the
russian armed forces but if putin is
losing so badly he's showing little sign
of remorse
fresh attacks in kiev give the lie to
russian claims they're scaling down
their offensive there
nato says they are pulling back only to
fight elsewhere russia is not
withdrawing
its forces but
repositioning them and
and that we can expect
reinforced russian
military
effort in the donbass region so so
russia continues to pursue a military
outcome of this conflict western spies
and commanders have put out a
coordinated message today that vladimir
putin has made a huge blunder by
invading ukraine but his commanders are
too scared to tell him the extent of it
if that is true he may well only double
down with a war that could have even
more devastating consequences
for civilians
putin went on the offensive economically
today demanding the west buys russian
gas in rubles a threat that may end up
with supplies being cut to europe
in order to buy russian natural gas they
have to open ruble accounts in russian
banks
from these accounts they'll be paying
for russian gas which will be delivered
from tomorrow first of april of this
year
if such payments are not made we will
consider this as a failure to carry out
the commitment
with all the consequences
we don't get anything free of charge and
we're not going to engage in charity
either
the latest drone pictures of mario paul
these taken by a russian journalist are
staggering
a european seaside city being torn apart
building by building by russian bombing
and shelling
a failure or not russia's leader remains
defiant with yet more mindless futile
destruction only likely to follow
dominic waghorn sky news la viv